Point chat gbt may not really need an
introduction
if you've used it you've probably seen
that it can often answer questions about
code Snippets help summarize documents
write coherent short stories and the
list goes on
now it has plenty of limitations and is
very capable of making mistakes but it
represents just how far language
modeling has come these past few years
in this video we'll specifically cover
the training objectives used to develop
chat gbt
the approach follows a similar
methodology to instruct GPT which was
released about a year prior
that model was specifically geared
towards instruction following the user
provides a single request and the model
outputs a response
chat gbt extends to more interactive
dialogues with back and forth messages
where the model can retain and use
context from earlier in an exchange
there are three main stages to the
training recipe
generative pre-training where we train a
raw language model on Text data
supervise fine-tuning where the model is
further trained to mimic ideal chatbot
Behavior demonstrated by humans
and reinforcement learning from Human
feedback where human preferences over
alternative model outputs will be used
to define a reward function for
additional training with RL
in each of these steps the model is
fine-tuned from the results of the step
prior that is its weights will be
initialized to the final weights
obtained in the previous stage
we'll step through these one by one
so first to refresh what is a language
model
well it's basically a special case of an
auto regressive sequence model given
some history of observed variables X1
through XT a basic sequence model is
tasked with predicting x t plus one
during training we extract sequences
from a data set and adjust the model's
parameters to maximize the probability
assigned to the true XT plus ones
conditioned on the histories
this next step prediction Paradigm has
been applied across different domains
like audio waveforms and molecular
graphs in the case of language models
the individual variables which we'll
refer to as tokens Can represent words
or sub-components of words
for example given the first four words
of the sentence a language model using
word tokens will output a probability
distribution over all the words in its
vocabulary indicating How likely each
word is to come next at least according
to the model's estimation
the vast majority of tokens would
receive close to zero probability as
they wouldn't make any sense here but a
few plausible ones will get some
non-zero probability Mass
now even though a language model is
simply trained to predict the next token
in Text data at inference time we
usually want to not just passively try
to predict but actually generate
sequences of tokens
at each step we can sample a token from
the probability distribution output by
the model and repeat this process over
and over until a special stop token is
selected
this setup is agnostic to the specific
model architecture used but typically
modern language models are large
Transformers consisting of billions of
parameters
I have a previous video diving into the
architectural details and math behind
Transformers
example models from the past few years
include gpt3 from openai or Palm from
Google
these are trained on massive amounts of
text scraped from the internet
chat forms blobs books scripts academic
papers code really anything
the amount of History the models can
condition on during inference has a
limit though
for chat gbt the underlying language
model can attend to about 3 000 words of
Prior context
so long enough for short conversations
but obviously not quite sufficient to
Output an entire novel
by pre-training on this large amount of
kind of unstructured heterogeneous Text
data we allow the model to learn
sophisticated probabilistic dependencies
between words sentences and paragraphs
across different use cases of human
language
so why is this generative modeling
formulation this basic language model
objective not enough why can't this
alone produce the end behavior we see
from chat gbt
well the user wants the model to
directly follow instructions or to
engage in an informative dialogue
so there's actually a misalignment
between the task implicit in the
language modeling objective and the
downstream task that the model
developers or end users want the model
to perform
the task represented by the language
model pre-training is actually a huge
mixture of tasks the user input is not
necessarily enough to disambiguate among
these
for example say a user provides this
input explain how the bubble sort
algorithm works
to us it's obvious what the user wants
the model to do but the model is only
trained to Output plausible completions
or continuations to pieces of text so
responding with a sentence like explain
how the merge storage algorithm works is
not entirely unreasonable
after all in its training data somewhere
there are documents that just contain
lists of questions on different topics
like exams
the task we want the model to perform is
actually just a subset of those
represented in the data now even without
any extra training we can often get a
language model to perform a desired task
via prompting we do this by first
conditioning the model on a manually
constructed example illustrating the
desired Behavior
but this is extra work on the part of
the user and can be tedious
in addition to the task being
underspecified for a raw language model
there are also subjective preferences
that the developers may have regarding
other characteristics of the model's
output
for example they may want the model to
refuse to answer queries seeking advice
for committing acts of violence or other
illicit activities
when dealing with a probabilistic model
it may be difficult to completely
eliminate violations of these
specifications but developers would like
to minimize their frequency if possible
so in the second stage the model will be
fine-tuned a bit with straightforward
supervised learning
human contractors first conduct
conversations where they play Both Sides
both the human user and the ideal chat
bot these conversations are aggregated
into a data set where each training
example consists of a particular
conversation history paired with the
next response of the human acting as the
chatbot
so given a particular history the
objective is to maximize the probability
the model assigns to the sequence of
tokens in the corresponding response
this can be viewed as a typical
imitation learning setup specifically
Behavior cloning where we attempt to
mimic an expert's action distribution
conditioned on an input state
so already with this step this does much
better than the raw language model at
responding to user requests with less
need for prompting but it still has
limitations
there's a problem of distributional
shift when it comes to this type of
imitative setting whether it's in
language or other domains like driving a
car or playing a game
the distribution of States during
training of the model is determined by
the expert policy the behavior of the
human demonstrator
but at inference time it's the model or
the agent itself that influenced the
distribution of visited States and in
general the model does not learn the
expert's policy exactly it may be able
to approximate it decently but a variety
of practical factors can limit this
approximation whether it's insufficient
training data partial observability of
the environment or optimization
difficulties
so as the model takes actions it may
make mistakes that the human
demonstrator was unlikely to and once
such an action takes place it can lead
to a new state that has lower support
under the training distribution this can
lead to a compounding error effect the
model may be increasingly prone to
errors as these novel states are
encountered where it has less training
experience
it can be shown theoretically that the
expected error actually grows
quadratically in the length of an
episode in the case of a language model
early mistakes May derail it causing it
to make overconfident assertions or
output complete nonsense
to mitigate this we need the model or
the agent to also act during training
not merely passively observe and expert
one way to do this is to further
fine-tune the model with reinforcement
learning
certain RL settings already come with a
predefined reward function
if we think about say Atari games then
there is an unambiguous reward collected
as the game progresses
without this we would typically need to
manually construct some reward function
but of course this is hard in the case
of language doing well in a conversation
is difficult to Define precisely
we could have labelers try to assign
numerical scores directly but it may be
challenging to calibrate these
instead the developers of chat GPT
establish a reward function based on
human preferences
AI trainers first have conversations
with the current model then for any
given model response a set of
alternative responses are also sampled
and a human labeler ranks them according
to most to least preferred to distill
this information into a scalar reward
suitable for reinforcement learning a
separate reward model initialized with
weights from the supervised model is
trained on these rankings how well given
a ranking over K outputs for a given
input we can Form K choose two training
pairs
the reward model will assign a scalar
score to each member of a pair
representing logits or unnormalized log
probabilities the greater the score the
greater the probability the model is
placing on that response being preferred
standard cross entropy is used for the
loss treating the reward model as a
binary classifier
once trained the scalar scores can be
used as Rewards
this will enable more interactive
training than the purely supervised
setting
during the reinforcement learning stage
our policy model that is the chat bot
will be fine-tuned from the final
supervised model
it emits actions its sequences of tokens
when responding to a human in a
conversational environment
given a particular state that is a
conversation history and a corresponding
action the reward model Returns the
numerical reward
the developers elect to use proximal
policy optimization or PPO as the
reinforcement learning algorithm here
we won't go into the details of PPO in
this video but this has been a popular
choice across different domains
now the Learned reward model we're
optimizing against here is a decent
approximation to the true objective we
care about the human subjective
assessment but it's still just an
approximation a proxy objective
in previous work it's been shown that
there's a danger of over optimizing this
kind of learned reward where the
policies performance eventually starts
degrading on the true Downstream task
even while the reward model scores
continue to improve the policy is
exploiting deficiencies in the Learned
reward model
this is reminiscent of good heart's law
which states when a measure becomes a
Target it ceases to be a good measure
so the authors of the instruct gpp paper
describe avoiding this over optimization
by applying an additional term to the
PPO objective penalizing the KL
Divergence between the RL policy and the
policy learned previously from
supervised fine-tuning
the combination of reward model learning
and PPO is iterated several times
at each iteration the updated policy can
be used to gather more responses for
preference ranking and a new reward
model is trained then the policy is
updated through another round of PPO
the two fine-tuning steps together that
is the supervised learning and the
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback have a dramatic effect on the
model's performance
for instruct GPT the predecessor model
to chat GPT evaluation showed that on
average labelers preferred responses
from a model with only quote unquote 1.3
billion parameters over the original 175
billion parameter gpt3 from which it was
fine-tuned
despite chat gpt's legitimately
sophisticated capabilities there is
still much room for improvement
it will sometimes spit out inaccurate or
completely made up facts and cannot link
out to explicit sources
and Its Behavior is still highly
dependent on the specific wording of an
input
even though prompting is far less needed
compared to a base language model
some amount of input hacking may still
be required depending on the specific
behavior desired
but of course these are interesting
questions to explore from here as new
models are developed building on top of
this progress
check out the links in the description
to learn more
thanks for watching